moving on
our main story tonight concerns
eyelashes among other things the reasons
that camels are so
sexy look without those luscious lashes
they'd just be lumpy horses with furry
back boobs but then you see those eyes
and you remember oh yeah
i'd totally a camel and by the way
i'm serious
we're gonna talk about eyelashes look
it's the summer there's a pandemic
raging and frankly i think we've all
earned a deep dive on how to best make
your eyelashes pop and to that end
there's a tick tock makeup tutorial that
i'd like you to take a look at
hi guys so i'm going to teach you guys
how to get long lashes so the first
thing you need to do is grab your lash
color
curl your lashes obviously then you're
going to put them down and use your
phone that you're using right now
to search up what's happening in china
how they're getting concentration camps
throwing innocent muslims in there
separating their families from each
other
hold up hold on that took quite a turn
there she went from promising longer
lashes to
discussing concentration camps in just
12 seconds and that's genuinely
impressive
look i'm a bit of an expert at taking
something fun and quickly ruining it so
this is game recognizing game here but
she
is right a lash curler is a vital tool
in anyone's beauty arsenal and
there's an ethnic group in china being
systematically surveilled and imprisoned
in an attempt to essentially wipe their
culture off the map and you know what
let's hold the eyelash story for another
week and instead let's talk about this
because
the people in question are the uyghurs
they're a mostly muslim ethnic minority
in a region of
china called xinjiang and the chinese
government has been treating them
absolutely terribly a u.n panel says the
region resembles
a massive internment camp where more
than one million muslim minorities
have been rounded up detained and
forcibly indoctrinated
by the chinese regime witness accounts
satellite imagery and communist party
documents
reveal what appears to be the largest
imprisonment of people
on the basis of religion since the
holocaust
wow saying anything is the largest since
the holocaust
automatically makes whatever you just
said worse the largest collection of
shoes
fun the largest collection of shoes
since the holocaust
oh boy all of a sudden really really not
fun
and if this is the first time that
you're hearing about an estimated
million people
who've been held in detention camps
mostly uyghurs but also kazakhs and
other ethnic minorities
you are not alone and it's probably
because china has done its level best
to keep this story from getting out but
it may be getting harder to
ignore just this week we learned that
you may actually have a personal
connection to this
without even knowing it because it turns
out uyghurs are being shipped and not
always willingly
to work in factories across china and
some of the products they've been making
may be right in front of your face if
you are one of the millions of people
around the world wearing a face mask
because of the coronavirus pandemic
this footage may concern you it shows a
group of uyghurs arriving at a textile
company that started producing masks in
response to the pandemic
we identified several chinese companies
that use weaker labor to produce ppe
and we tracked some of their shipments
to consumers in the u.s and around the
world
yeah it's true the very masks that some
in this country see as
unacceptable infringement on their
personal liberty may be getting made
by people who would absolutely love for
their worst infringement to be getting
politely asked to leave a costco
and while there is clearly nothing new
about horrific practices being hidden
deep in the supply chain of global
capitalism what is happening to the
uyghurs
is particularly appalling so tonight
let's talk about them who they are
what's been happening to them and why
and let's start with a bit of context
about 11 million uighurs live in
xinjiang in the
far northwest corner of china it's
resource rich
and it's strategically important but
weakers have always had an uncomfortable
relationship
with the authorities in beijing they
have their own language and are
culturally and ethnically distinct
from the rest of china's population
which is more than 90 percent
han chinese on top of which there's the
fact that uyghurs are
muslim in a country that is aggressively
secular so much so
that a few years ago a chinese reality
show went to dubai and state tv
centered all depictions of a woman in a
headscarf in the weirdest
possible way covering it with a cartoon
helmet
and a shock of yellow hair with a ghost
in it
and covering her hijab by obscuring her
completely
with a cactus in a santa hat even doing
that when she was reflected in another
person's sunglasses and look
setting aside the issue of religious
freedom for a second
that's an amazing way to censor someone
out of a tv show
i'm just saying watching old episodes of
house of cards would be much less
uncomfortable
if it looked like this instead why did
you ask him to leave
because i just wanted to look in your
eyes
one more time before we do this
francis we're doing this
see that's just objectively much better
and now you can enjoy house of cards
just as much as you used to which was
a bit so there was that baseline
difference there
on top of which some han chinese have
held bigoted views
about the weakest in fact just listen to
this interview from back in 2008
here in beijing uyghurs are dispersed
across the city
many work at restaurants and street
stalls
they stand out because of their
different features and dress
some han chinese are blatantly
prejudiced against them
the people from xinjiang are not very
good
and thief wow robbers and thieves that
is
not an acceptable way to describe an
entire ethnic group
it's barely an acceptable way to
describe all raccoons i mean yeah they
are essentially just kleptomaniac
possums who steal your trash with their
spooky little doll hands
but that's not all that they are and all
of this was exacerbated by the chinese
government
encouraging han people to migrate to
xinjiang with them
often being favored over uighurs for top
jobs and these tensions
and resentments amid an overall
atmosphere of extreme discrimination
finally boiled over in 2009 with riots
in the capital that killed 200 people
mostly han chinese but rather than
address the complex underlying factors
behind those riots and other incidents
the chinese government simply painted
them as religious terrorism beginning
a decade-long crackdown that escalated
steadily especially
after china's president xi jinping came
to power and instituted what was called
the strike hard campaign against violent
terrorism
in 2014 and think of it as the patriot
act
on steroids because all of a sudden
uyghurs started being treated
like they were all potential terrorists
in fact xinjiang is now one of the most
heavily policed areas
in the world with the authority
surveilling things that most people
would find
utterly meaningless if you go through
weaker neighborhoods or suburbs you see
cameras
over literally every house entrance so
the government can see
who enters and who leaves how low is the
bar for being
highlighted by the system are you
socializing more or less with your
neighbors
have you put gas in somebody else's car
are you going out the front door of your
house instead of the back door of your
house
that's how low the bar is oh it goes
even further
the government has a list of 75
behavioral indications of religious
extremism with some as vague as
people who store large amounts of food
those who smoke and drink but quit
doing so quite suddenly and those who
buy or store equipment such as dumbbells
without obvious reasons although that
last one clearly would not be an issue
for me because
i've got two pretty obvious reasons for
dumbbell ownership
right here it's not called a workout if
you don't put the work in bro
seth bron rad trust me they call me the
lunch lady because from the hours of 11
to 1
i don't stop stacking plates i call this
one john
and this one taffa because together they
lift
up bars but look china doesn't just
collect
this information it feeds it into a
predictive policing system
that monitors four potential threats in
one week it flagged the names of 24
000 people as suspicious 15 000 of whom
were then sent to re-education camps and
when pressed on whether
any of this is strictly necessary
chinese officials will argue that they
are simply being proactive
some people before they commit murder
already show they are capable of it
should we wait for them to commit a
crime or prevent it from happening
okay that is both insane logic and also
the exact plot of minority report which
if you haven't seen it very briefly the
years 2054
tom cruise's john anderton is chief of
washington dc's pre-crime police
department where murders are stopped
before they happen now ethically there
are some questions about the system for
instance
can you really be sure an individual
will commit to the crimes that the
pre-cogs say they'll commit oh yeah the
precogs they are
balls freaks who sleep in an indoor
swimming pool and they scream whenever
they visualize a future murder i think
they're all siblings or aliens or babies
i can't remember but basically the
murder rate in the city is zero
anderson's doing well and so the status
quo remains now one day the pre-cults
generate a prediction
john anderson will murder a man he
doesn't even know in just 36 hours but
it couldn't be
that's our hero isn't it so he stages an
escape
gets an eye transplant so he can't be
detected by the city's eye-based
surveillance system
finds out he's being framed then finds
out that max von siddow oh yeah by the
way he's in this too
is going to kill anderson but decides
not to and anderson doesn't kill the
person that
he supposedly was going to disproving
the very basis of the pre-crime system
and proving that people do
have free choice so in the end they shut
down the program
and send the precogs away to live on a
farm but not the death kind
we assume anyway it's scary but it's
pretty good
i'd say three stars but the bigger point
is
people in xinjiang have been arrested
and thrown in camps
despite having committed no crimes which
is chilling
a million uyghurs were at one point
being held extra judicially
many for acts as innocuous as growing a
beard fasting
or applying for a passport and this is a
very sore
subject for the chinese government which
initially denied the existence of the
camps at all
before shifting to arguing that they are
merely vocational training facilities
although
even the heavily orchestrated media
tours suggest their primary purpose
might be something else authorities
recently took some diplomats and
journalists on a carefully supervised
tour of some of these facilities some
detainees told journalists the camps
re-educate them
and luckily enough the communist party
and the government offer this kind of
school to us for free
holy that might be the single
creepiest sing-along
i've ever heard that doesn't involve
barney a dinosaur who is
clearly aware of clothing he's wearing a
hat and yet still
actively chooses to go bottomless around
children you
are an absolute monster and for all the
chinese government's talk of
vocational training these camps sure
seem
prison-like leaked classified documents
have shown that staff at these
facilities were told to
prevent students from freely contacting
the outside world
and that they should strictly manage and
control student activities
to prevent escapes and the phrase
prevent
escapes is something of a tell there if
your employee handbook says
prevent escape you're probably working
at a prison or at the very least
a scientology picnic hey we're just here
to grill some dogs
play some tunes and if anyone asks where
shelley is
do not let them escape and look if that
weren't enough
to make it clear what these camps really
are just listen to one former detainee
describe
what she went through each woman gets
two minutes to go to the toilet
they tell you to be quick quick quick if
you're not quick enough
they shock you with an electric baton on
the back of your head
it really hurt and they did it a lot
even after being shocked we had to say
thank you teacher we will not be late
next time
that is clearly absolutely appalling
i didn't think people had to publicly
thank abusers anymore now that harvey
weinstein doesn't go to award shows and
look
i'm not even getting into the reports of
forced abortions
and sterilizations of uyghur women which
are absolutely horrific
and china will argue that this is all
about economic opportunity
and attempting to assimilate a
historically ostracized minority but
assimilation
when forced is cultural erasure because
in addition to using mass detention to
keep families apart there are also rules
that seem to be trying to break the
chain by which families hand down
a culture and faith across generations
from laws preventing kids from going to
mosques to a ban on
baby names that are considered to
islamic to the creation of state-run
boarding schools
for weaker children now other moves by
china have been
even more on the nose like the
destruction of uyghur cemeteries
the government actually turned an
enormous graveyard where a prominent
uyghur poet was buried into something
called
happiness park complete with fake pandas
children's rides and a man-made lake and
look i'm not saying
that this is the most important thing
but this is one of the pandas in
question
and frankly i have never had more
questions why is he holding a lollipop
why does he have the posture of a
startled gopher why does he have an
expression that screams i just had a
lobotomy but it turns out i'm both happy
about it
and surprisingly horny frustratingly we
may never know the answers
now thankfully as criticism of china's
camps has intensified
in recent years the government seems to
be closing some of them unfortunately
though
they seem to have shifted to staging
sham trials
and transferring many uyghurs to prisons
that aren't even pretending to be
training centers anymore
china's also created a system of mass
labor transfers that sends weakers
and other ethnic minorities into factory
and service jobs sometimes hundreds
or thousands of miles from home that is
how
those masks that we mentioned at the
start of this piece are getting made
and chinese state media presents this as
a positive showing
weaker workers arriving at a train
station then being taken
on a bus to their new accommodations all
with upbeat narration like this
up to now has organized transfers for
around 178 000 workers
providing them a stable employment rate
of over 92 percent
yeah you can't celebrate a stable
workforce when it is
forced labor any more than you give me
credit for spending a lot of time with
my kids over the past few months believe
me
if i had any other choice i wouldn't be
because as you've probably guessed
this isn't just a benevolent jobs
program the idea as one local government
report put it
is that sending uighurs far from home
will allow for distancing them from
religiously extreme views
and educating them and a lot of people
have been distanced
one australian think tank that
investigated forced labour estimated
that conservatively
over just a two-year period more than 80
uyghurs were transferred out of xinjiang
to work in factories across
china they also found over 80 companies
directly or indirectly
benefiting from uighur labor in their
supply chain some of them
big international brands like nike when
the washington post
visited the factory of one of nike
suppliers it found weaker workers were
forced to attend patriotic education and
mandarin classes and
living dormitories under constant
supervision with one worker saying
we can walk around but we can't go back
to xinjiang on our own
now nike has claimed that this factory
no longer employs weaker workers and
they told us that they take
any reports about forced labor seriously
and they're conducting ongoing diligence
with our suppliers in china which given
what the post found feels like their
policy on oversight is less just do it
than
just talk about doing it and hope people
eventually stop asking and look
it's not just nike another company on
the list is volkswagen which told us
they found no indications of forced
labor in their supply chain
though it is worth noting that last year
their ceo was challenged about whether
china's treatment of the uyghurs gave
him pause
and this was his response i'm we are
absolutely proud to also create
workplaces
in that region which we think is very
useful but xinjiang
is something you're not proud to be
associated with in terms of what the
chinese government is doing to
weaker people i can't uh judge this
sorry you can't judge it no
but you know about it i don't know what
you're referring to you don't know about
china's re-education camps for a million
weaker people
that is it has referred to as
re-education camps as part of its
counter-terror threat in the west of
this country
you don't know about that i'm not aware
of that
wow finding out that volkswagen is
overlooking a massive human rights
crisis
is kind of a lot like finding out your
grandparents are still having sex
sure it's completely horrifying but it
really shouldn't be too shocking after
all
they've been doing it since world war ii
and look
i can understand why companies and
others might want to turn away from
what's going on in xinjiang because
it's harrowing remember that woman who
got electric shocks for taking too long
in the bathroom she was in two different
camps
then was transferred into forced labor
at a glove factory all
while separated from her family for two
years and while they were eventually
reunited they are understandably
still haunted to this day for two years
you didn't see your mom
[Music]
that is heartbreaking and completely
indefensible
and whenever pressed on this the chinese
government has been quick to use
what about ism they responded to us
criticism by invoking atrocities ranging
from
the genocide of native americans to a
statement that read george floyd's death
shows that u.s systemic racism has
choked ethnic minorities so hard that
they
can't breathe and look those are fair
hits
those are fair points right there but
it's also completely possible
for two things to be wrong at the same
time and i know
the u.s china relationship is
complicated particularly right now and
too often
it descends into reductive xenophobic us
versus them
stereotypes but human rights should be
completely non-negotiable
and i will say the us has taken some
small steps here like imposing sanctions
against top chinese officials and
congress even passed the uyghur human
rights policy act
earlier this year but although trump
signed it he also reportedly told xi
jinping that he should go ahead with
building the camps
because he thought it was exactly the
right thing to do
which from a foreign policy perspective
a human rights perspective
a political perspective and even an
interpersonal perspective
is exactly the wrong thing to do
but look
this clearly isn't just about trump is
it going forward
the entire global community needs to do
more the un
should have independent investigators
looking into what china has done in
xinjiang
governments around the world should be
speaking out about the treatment of the
uyghurs without bending to china's
economic influence and big
multinational companies like nike and vw
should not only
be working to clean up their supply
chains but also
actively using their financial leverage
to pressure the chinese government to
end these abuses but none of that is
going to happen
unless people pay attention and look i
know that
raising awareness is often a
solution
that doesn't really solve a problem but
there can be a real benefit to awareness
even if it is coming through a tick-tock
makeup tutorial or let's say
the exact opposite of one because in
this instance
awareness is actually a necessary
precondition for action and i know
there is a lot to worry about right now
from a raging pandemic
to an ugly presidential election to a
purple pervert who couldn't give a
about pants but
we have to make sure that the treatment
of uyghurs is also on that list
because when you're dealing with a
concerted campaign centered on cultural
erasure
one of the most important things we can
do is continue to pay attention
at the very least so that if an entire
culture is replaced by a horny
lobotomized panda
will know to stand up and say
something
you